- Oh yeah, that's a good duo.
- That smells really good.
- That's delicious.
- I'd wear this as a perfume.
(rock music)
- I love cookies. I love butter.
I don't know why I wouldn't like this.
- I mean, if there's a
way to make cookie better,
to put it in liquid form so
you can ingest it faster.
- I think it's gonna taste
like creamy cookie dough.
- It's gonna taste like melted cookies.
- And angels.
- What is Speculoos?
- That is the name of an old clock maker
with a hidden past.
- Yeah.
- All you have to do is
taste it to understand.
Well, isn't that how food goes?
Like, what are you talkin' about?
- Isn't that like a pickup line
that some dude would
probably say to a girl?
- Cheers.
(mysterious background music)
- That's quite delightful.
- It's like a sweet peanut butter.
- It tastes like a Teddy
Graham melted in my mouth.
- Yeah.
- It's like if you just
melted down cookies,
like whipped em up
and then put it in this little candle jar.
- It's like peanut butter and Christmas.
- I would definitely consider mix,
like just experimenting with this,
gettin' crazy with it.
- Like, this is thick.
This is like,
- This is real thick.
- Cement for your mouth.
- It's like eating a mouthful of mud,
but good mud!
- Seriously, you could
put this on anything.
You could put this on my ex-boyfriend
and it would make him better.
- I think it's really
great to have this kind of
cookie taste but in more
of a spreadable form.
I'm into it.
- You just want it to
be socially acceptable
to have cookies for breakfast.
- Yeah.
- I can't talk.
- My mouth is still full of this stuff.
- Almost butter or cashew butter.
Everything's butter these days, ya know?
Let's step away from butter
and let's just think like,
do we even need it?
- You butter believe it.
(electronic upbeat music)